how do you marry this need for hard work
yeah with the insights that you have
around envisioning your future uh I I
don't uh I just want to Define hard work
um uh first because um I think um I
don't see hard work as the way people
see hard work I I mean I'm a I'm a very
immersive person so if I'm going to get
good at something um I'm going to put my
my mind my body my heart and soul behind
whatever it is I'm going to do and and I
do that because I like it you know I
like to learn I like to experience I
like to grow um and I think um you can
get really good at doing it one way and
the hard work the you know all the stuff
we talked about get really good at doing
it and become successful and then have
what just about everything you want but
you may not truly have happiness you
just may have a lot of things and you
got really good at doing it right okay
so for me I said there's got to be
another way there's got to be another
way to do it that's different than the
way that I've done it I've got gotten
really good at doing that is there
another way to create where I don't
actually have to go and do something if
I could change my energy and I've been
at this long enough to tell you that
nobody changes until they change their
energy if I change my energy will my
life change that's that's kind of the
experiment that I'm interested in okay
so what piece of knowledge what piece of
information let me find the information
that can help me build the model of
understanding that this is actually
possible now I'm not watching Flix I'm
not watching Ted lasso I'm not watching
Suits I'm not watching the news I'm not
watching the game I'm I'm I'm reading
this information because I want to
understand the what and the why okay now
I got it okay quantum physics says
Einstein says the field is the sole
governing agency of the particle the the
field controls the particle particle
doesn't control the particle energy
controls matter okay all right let me
build this model a little bit further
okay um if if if the field is soul
governing agency of the particle then
it's not matter that's emitting the
field it's actually a field that's
actually slowing down in frequency and
creating matter okay I'm telling you all
this because I'm using I'm using quantum
physics as a way to help us understand
that mind and matter are inextricably
combined it's impossible to separate the
two okay well it works on a very tiny
level of subatomic particles but can can
it work on a on a greater level can can
you make real life events happen in your
life and collapse the wave function okay
well if I'm matter trying to change
matter if I'm Joe dispenza aware that
I'm local in space and time immersed in
the illusion of this virtual reality
experience this this hologram then I got
to pray by the play by the rules of
nutonian physics but you got to predict
and plan and do a lot of things okay
okay what if I could get to the field
what if I could become pure
Consciousness and be aware of nothing
physical and material become nobody
become no one in nothing in nowhere in
no time become pure Consciousness and
move to that realm beyond space space
and time okay let me just say okay if I
could get there as pure Consciousness
and I'm not aware of my body not aware
of my environment not aware of time and
I'm in the field okay what are the
principles of the field U everything's
connected everything's frequency
everything's energy um there's less
separation there's more wholeness okay
so if I could get to the field and I can
create from the field instead of from
matter as an experiment could I then
begin to produce changes in the field
that ultimately would change the the
Hologram and threedimensional reality
okay so I may not be very good at it at
the beginning so it's going to take some
unlearning and changing my beliefs about
a lot of things and studying the make
sure that when I do it that I know what
I'm doing and why I'm doing it okay uh
so nothing happens do I go back to just
going back the other way or is I just
not that good so maybe I'm just not that
good yet like maybe I got to get better
at it so I'm going to practice again um
I'm going to keep building my model
through experience and then all of a
sudden you start noticing changes now
the hard work was worth the effort when
I start seeing the effects that it
creates in my life
so I think that that there's a delicate
balance between intention and that's
getting clear on what you want and
surrender uh which means trusting in the
outcome and if you over intend you're
working really hard and you're trying
really hard and if you over surrender
you're lazy and lethargic and you're not
doing anything right so it's kind of a
Razor's Edge when you talk about hard
work because for me um it really is
about building a model of understanding
and then being able to immerse myself in
the experience to prove to myself that
it actually uh could be the truth so the
hard work is just good clean effort and
getting so lost in the act of what
you're doing that the ACT actually
becomes the experience I know that for
me when I get to that point where I've
stretched myself past the point where I
normally stop especially in a meditation
if I go one more time it's always worth
the effort something changes uh when I
when I go past that point so and I think
that's that works in all kinds of ways
so um I think hard work for me is just
immersing myself in it to until I start
seeing effects there's a line from
mackiei where he says God doesn't want
to do everything some of it is up to you
I think that's a nice blending of those
two yeah I have another friend who um we
were at a party my birthday party
actually last year and we were walking
back toward his car who was parked
nearby and uh he was going to give me a
lift home and I was waiting for him to
beep the car so that I could get in and
he didn't and the door was open did you
not lock your car he says oh I don't
lock my car that's interesting why don't
you do that he says I'm not sure man the
universe just has my back and locking
your car I think that's just that's a
sufficient low lift that you might as
well do it anyway but that line really
stuck with me the universe has my back
and the times when I feel like that's
the case the times when I feel like I'm
swimming Downstream not Upstream uh
life's better yeah undeniably life's
better well you may have to put 10 in
and get one out in the beginning and
then if you stick with it you put one in
you get 10 out and that's when it gets
fun so there'll be a lot of people
listening who
again the people who pray at the altar
of raw cognition right very
very utilitarian material istic that
left brain is always
on how can they learn to expand a view
of what contributes to happiness and
well-being and fulfillment and
achievement in life what would you say
to the person who's still unsure well um
I think it was last year we were at an
event a week-long event and we were we
do a lot of walking meditations because
you got to be able to stand as it walk
as it sit as it lay down as it and so we
do a lot of walk meditations to to to
embody it and um I was it was in Cancun
Mexico there was 2200 people at that
event we were on the beach it's at
Sunrise the sun was coming up this was
one of the last meditations you know and
I just I looked at all these people and
they were looking facing the sun they
had their hands over their heart and
their eyes were closed so many of them
like had tears of joy uh rolling down
their face they were so incredibly
joyful so
incredibly grateful um so worthy uh in
that moment and I realized my God
nobody's making them happy in that
moment but them and and I think when we
hit these points where we finally break
free from the chains you know of our own
limitations I think when we overcome the
emotional addictions that keep us
tormented and reliving the past uh I
think um that the the the overcoming of
those emotional addictions the side
effect is joy is it's it's it's a
freedom of expression without feeling
limited uh in any way and I just I can
tell you that um again this is only my
experience but when I look at an
audience of people you know at the end
of seven days and um I always tell them
uh nobody's making you happy but you and
all you've done is decided who not to be
and who to be and sat with yourself long
enough to change that so when people do
that and they get to that point where um
they're worthy to
receive they showed up enough times when
they could have laid in bed or skipped a
meditation but they didn't that they
they kept showing up I think the
universe only gives us what we think
we're worthy of receiving right and so
the person who's feeling that level of
um happiness that level of Joy because
they've made themselves happy then
they're okay with you and they're okay
with everybody and I and I think uh
that's the important point is that that
when we overcome ourselves the side
effect of of that is true joy in other
news this episode is brought to you by
momentus a lot of supplements say that
they're top quality but very few can
actually prove it and momentus has the
most rigorous third-party testing of any
supplement company that I've ever found
Andrew hubman is the scientific adviser
for them my favorite product from them
is their sleep pack which contains
everything that you need for a good
night's sleep including magnesium L3 38
appenine and eleanine in the optimal
doses to help you get a better deeper
more restful night's sleep this is all
that you need you can throw it in your
bag you can take it with you on the road
or you can just take it every single
evening it's made a massive difference
to the quality of my sleep best of all
they've got a 30-day money back
guarantee so you can buy anything and
try it for 29 days and if you don't like
it they will give you your money back
they ship internationally and you can
get free us shipping on orders over $75
right now you can get 20% discount on
everything sitewide by going to the link
in the description below or heading to
Liv mous.com slod wisdom using the code
modern wisdom a checkout that's Liv
mous.com mod wisdom and modern wisdom a
checkout thank you very much for tuning
in if you enjoyed that clip with Joe you
will love the fulllength three-hour long
podcast in all its Glory right here go
on give it a tap